is dude look at that big spider gift
Livingston Sango never thought he'd be
doing this showing his son artwork done
in the 1940s by his late father
Livingston Sango his son's grandfather
the paintings are part of an exhibition
at the National Gallery in Zimbabwe's
Capital Harare a collection done more
than 70 years ago by young black
students at Cyrene Anglican Mission
School some of this picture I'm singing
for the first time in my life when we
started these exhibitions I don't think
he even remembered them but here we are
I am now seeing my father at the age of
18 when I only remember him as an
ornament
Cyrene Anglican Mission School was the
first school to teach art to black
children in what was then white minority
ruled Rhodesia the most special thing
about this collection is that it went on
a world tour in the 1940s from 1947 to
1953 so the rest of the world saw these
artworks in the 40s and 50s and
absolutely loved it but zimbabweans had
never seen the artworks before after
that tour unsold artworks were stored in
the basement of a church in the UK where
they were forgotten for years in the
1970s they were rediscovered and sold to
an art collector who then sold the
collection to a Zimbabwean
philanthropist in the diaspora the Stars
a bright exhibition is now briefly back
home this is a picture of my father
his name was Claxton William candier
lianda candiero a popular radio
presenter here says it's been amazing
putting together the pieces of his
family's history his father died in
1990. We Are history we are a result of
History this is a history that I'll
share with my children I've already
bought them here anyway
this is a history that I am taking back
to my mom the wife to say did you know
that your husband did this you didn't
know artwork that was sold during the
world tour in the late 1940s and early
1950s helped to fund the school and pay
for scholarships for some of the
students the paintings and drawings
cover a seven year period and represent
just a small selection of more than 600
works from one collection hundreds more
exists in public and private collections
around the world after this exhibition
in Zimbabwe the art will tour abroad
again with calls for the repatriation of
African art to the continent growing
some locals want to see the Cyrene
paintings returned home permanently
haramutasa Al Jazeera Harare